[Musique]
il ya 50 ans les enjeux sociaux du
territoire au conduit à la création de
la rage ufat l'association réunionnaise
de l'aide judiciaire aux familles
accompagnent toutes les victimes et
favorise l'accès au droit
une table ronde a ainsi permis
d'échanger avec acteurs sociaux et
judiciaires les partenaires associatifs
et sur tout le département
sans le soutien du département peut pas
grand chose parce que vous savez le nerf
de la guerre c'est des sous donc il ya
quand même 17 employés
c'est ses employés il faut les payer et
je crois que étant donné des 40 % de
personnes qui vivent en dessous du seuil
de la pauvreté à la réunion pour qu'ils
aient les mêmes droits que ceux qui le
peuvent
la rage ufac totalement indispensable
50' leur a juste pas cinq ans taux
d'évolution des collectivités accompagne
ainsi ses actions de proximité depuis le
13 novembre 1969
et si la société évolue les textes le
réglementaire évolue aussi tout comme
les problèmes liés notamment aux
violences conjugales que nous sommes à
la veille d'une nouvelle collaboration
parce qu'il convient de renforcer les
moyens aussi bien département comme dans
les associations qui font de la
prévention
et quand nous faisons de la prévention
on évite des drames en évite des
problèmes et c'est pour cela que les
associations comme la rage du fa et dot
sur le territoire sont bien utiles et le
département est fier de les accompagner
ainsi le président du département et le
président de la rage ou far ont signé
une déclaration
l'objectif est de réaffirmer ses valeurs
et l'importance de ses missions a porté
en direction des publics les plus
fragiles
[Musique]